e
e e
the context of this is just we got
everybody to report the beginning and
ending under the same Bal like the
actual beginning and ending in the same
manner and then we put the commitments
or the encumbrances sort of off to the
side as sort of just a barometer but
it's not in the math so are you do you
want to change the math
now not go into minut okay because we
didn't discuss it that way okay but one
of the things that should be understood
from this committee is that when if we
set a cap on the fund balance ah okay
okay that it should be that cap should
be calculated based on the amount in the
fund at the end of the
year with the
dedicated money you know so if there's a
if there a million two in a fund and
we're setting a cap at a million but
there's 200,000 that's obligated they're
good they're good yes agreed
okay right that we're not going to say
they had a million to even though they
had the obligated stuff we're going to
cut them down to a million so that take
out the obligation right they're at
right the the challenge with the
obligations is it's all just a timing
Factor so that's why we sort of put it
off to the side because it's not
relevant to the balance it it's relevant
in that to the reader but it's a timing
of when they cut the checks so
right right
so the way I'm going to do it is for for
the purpose of these minutes going to
cross off and the annual funding to
produce the next budget and change that
to and the balance be C at a million
dollar but for the for the final report
we will
you could say the end the ending balance
is the name of the column that shows up
in the report that's the number you're
looking at that just that number so you
could use that terminology I don't want
to use that
okay no I'm with you you want to sort of
do the math
ahead
right
e
e e
I'm I'm told we're being streamed so we
will use the microphone
so so again you know I want them to come
back to me if they want to do something
with that legislation that makes sense
because if they've got a half a million
dollars in there and the only problem
was that they couldn't buy a
$300,000 that's an internal problem
that's not a g you know our problem
that's the they
problem
so all right other changes to the
minutes I want to go back to the
previous one and just instead of saying
a workable quum
uh a work an unworkable Quorum
requirement because that's what oh back
to the Quorum thing on page two second
paragraph paragraph
after
failing
to why don't you say after failing to
make a
quorum that's all you need to do and
then comment later the it was the Forum
was shut higher than
normal oh I see yeah well the reason was
because they have a 17 member commission
with a 15 member Quorum right so
[Laughter]
and at their first attempt at a meeting
uh a person I will not name uh insisted
that they do it that way okay
um I mean do you want to say the law
requires a 15 no no why don't not just
say failing to make calls okay fine like
you were saying okay all
right any other
changes no all right the first paragraph
Yes
um something
there second sentence accounts in a
system not in funded by the general fund
in uh which page we page one first
page second paragraph about State
Treasurer oh
yeah by adding existing accounts in her
system not in funded by the general fund
in
is it in the bottom of the paragraph I
can't by add it's the very first
sentence very top by adding existing
counts in her system not in funded oh
not funded by the general okay take away
the word
in yes good good catch
I I am more than halfway towards
cataract surgery oh yeah it's getting a
little
difficult okay all right good move to
approve as
amended okay all those in favor I I any
oppos okay unanimous thank you Senator
Greg all right good so that's it for the
minutes now let's have the treasurer and
com ER talk to us about their
proposal good morning Mr chairman
members of the committee for the record
uh State dire Monica
miselli um so we shared um our latest
draft and um the draft that you have um
in front of you is what we discussed at
the last meeting and then um the
committee requested that uh the
controller and I viewed the funds in the
list of RSA
612 that are prefer as trust but um
essentially that for financial report
and purposes they're not or or in
general they're not true trust so we
highlighted what we tried to highlight
are um some of I the ones that we we
agreed uh control and I agreed that
they're not trust and also they're not
reported as such um so initially I had
some color for you but um my number in
didn't work so you have uh no color but
um I can start identifying the funds I
can go Page by Page identifying those
funds
um if if you would like to proceed that
way uh the other piece I want to mention
is
um in addition to the the review that we
did of those those funds um controller
call also is proposing some um language
change to the reporting
requirements uh in and and and I believe
she's going to elaborate on that so
that's at the end of this this version
this draft but I can start reviewing uh
again the initial request by the
committee I'm guessing that all the
things that you're proposing changing
are are either crossed out or or
highlighted in bold
um that is correct or have a background
gray that is correct and and and we
didn't all all we did in this in this
um in this version for again the request
of the committee was highlight those
funds are called trust and in we didn't
change anything is they're just
highlighted for us to discuss for the
committee to to review and ask questions
so for example on page three correct you
highlighted education trust fund so that
is actually in law right now and you're
not proposing to change it but you
highlighted it because it has the word
trust in it cor right correct based on
based on again the committee's request
to identify those in this list are not
true trust they're just by name trust
although the ucation trust fund has
other potential consequences if the name
was changed perhaps I don't know but we
just wanted to ident identify for you to
to
review okay represent voling yes use
your
microphone on P
page oh these oh there's the page page
six is the first example I think of I
think it's the first example of maybe a
number of them uh 167 about 2third of
the way down um you've just
bolded permanent or endowment instead of
agency fund and since we don't have
colors I'm not sure we're going to if
there's anything new that we're going to
miss them so um again the only reason so
I have some I actually have five copies
in color I don't have six this is why we
didn't distribute them because I I
missed the number but I have some if you
want to go by color it's it's there you
could have both if you like
well am I correct in this particular
example the words permanent and
endowment are not currently in law and
you're replacing agency by those two
words maybe we can share two
of thank
you it makes it a lot easier to
find I'm
by the time this Bill gets to the Senate
it's going to be changed
anyway maybe yeah
maybe so so back to my question so the
words permanent and endowment on line
167 on page six yeah and if you recall
are new yes so I maybe we need to recap
what we discussed last time so for
example what uh represent Al is
referring to um initially my what we
what we reviewed last time was the fact
that we were um just clarifying the
language of RSA 612 c and d and one of
the comments that I made uh for example
to to remove the war agency the war
agency again a financial reporting
purposes that became a problematic and
confusing uh that's why the the the um
the pronouncement were changed to to
call it something different now it's
called custodial accounts so um the the
number 167 and 16 um think it's just 67
uh it's just it's just again just
following the same um format and
removing the word agency here and I
think the other piece that we discussed
last time is the fact that this RSA 612
also
[Music]
includes um
um those not what's listed under SI 612
C and D is also listed under RSA
612 and maybe if I recall correctly you
were um thinking about maybe moving the
these two numbers and others to the top
to try to clarify if I recall uh a brief
conversation about that
um okay uh but I did so I didn't change
that
and um again this this this this
particular version the only difference
is that we highlighted the the word
trust for your um for your consideration
as you were um you had questions about
some in
particular represent yeah now that we've
got
colors uh there there are ones that are
bolded on in green the trust you will
see in green that's correct yeah oh so
that's uh all places where the word
trust exists correct oh okay correct I'm
glad that's helpful whether or not it's
appropriate because it certainly is for
lchip which is so for example I wouldn't
include some of
them in the list of R 6612 C and D
because they're not first of all we
don't have them as separate off book
accounts they're just they live in the
accounting system system some of them
are Appropriations for example on page
five you will see um the El chip program
the lchip trust that's really an
appropriation by the state it lives in
the it lives in the operating budget um
but they've always had the name of lchip
trust um but it's not a true trust in a
way really
um it's certainly not maintained
separate but you're not trying to move
it to C C or D I'm not unless you have
um unless you're suggest that and and
and again
um and and and probably the controller
could help me here because some of them
as they're just State business and and
they're just funds that handle the
activity of that particular
program so uh they're not real trust
they're not endowments this is why I
wouldn't put him under RSA 6C for
example would you like me to jump in
Dana call com troller for the record um
I think what we were we're trying to do
there's a lot of moving and shaking here
and and a followup to a conversation you
got you all had I wasn't here but I
think um one of the goals of
reorganizing this section is to make um
for the treasurer it clear in the C and
D sections what are two TR true trusts
permanent endowment and then indeed
custodial Arrangements that really
there's another control over those funds
there's an outside legal purpose
document whatever it may be unlike all
of the items that are numbered 1 through
395 which are more uh dedicated for a
particular purpose and the purview of
this Committee in my view I I would
stand corrected if you've feel
differently but I I think what we're
trying to do is simplify the true trusts
permanent funds endowment funds that
have true legal structures around them
get reported currently in three
different Publications by the state um
the treasurer has to report them in her
annual report I need to report them in
the state's audit and they go in the
dedicative funds report and and MO two
out of three of these are very manual
processes like I I think that one of the
goals is that I feel this report um in
my view is very valuable for dedicated
funds that are numbered 1 through 395
because there is no other report that in
the state that gives you the detail that
you're looking for whereas trust funds
endowment funds permanent funds the
treasurer is required to report those in
her annual reports with the level of
detail that would be the bare minimum
that would be required so I think what
we're trying to do is simplify which I
think is a goal of this committee still
provide for items that are numerically
in the first portion of 612 still
provide a page in this report for you to
do your review but if it's reported
elsewhere in a different capacity and
there's a different set of rules and
structures we're trying to sort of carve
those out and for that reason I added a
proposal at the very end of the document
to remove those trust funds with that
are in C and D to to take them out of
the exempt them from the reporting
requirements similar to what we did two
years ago when we Exempted the entire
lior Commission because that's a
separate annual report already you know
for example or the education trust fund
the highway fund those funds are all
separately reported under other
accounting or statutory requirements
whereas your regular dedicated funds 1
through 395 really don't have a separate
reporting requirement elsewhere so they
kind of go in the book so we're trying
to make those distinctions so we're not
duplicating efforts across Publications
but also provide you really the detail
that you want in doing your annual
reviews that's pres
wer could we just simply remove the word
trust from the areas that are
highlighted in
green some of those if yes I think if
you not the education trust fund I would
not suggest we we touch that one but for
instance the opio de batement trust or
the drinking water groundwater trust if
they're not currently a true trust you
may want to make them that in the future
but if they're not currently they would
just be a fund and they would go in the
dedicated fund book at the level of
detail that you need to do your review
because right now for instance the
drinking water groundwater trust is in
my financial statements part of the
general fund it's it's it's in BL Ed in
that column so this book gives you an
extra level of detail on that particular
fund but you don't need to call it a
trust in order to get that reporting you
just give it a dedicated fund number and
it goes you call it a trust then the
next question is who are the trustees
correct like there's and and and the
answer is
huh in some of those cases there was
original legislation that established
who who manages the funds or the trust
but in the legal terms it's not
necessarily addressed thank you Senator
U Rosen thank you but specifically in
reference the opioid abatement trust
fund it um when that whole chapter was
established the name of the fund was
called the trust fund it's really a
settlement
fund we would have to change the
underlying
statute to change the name of that and
there's reluctance to go and keep
reopening that statute for various
reasons I would agree I I I don't know
if that's something you'd want to do in
a future year I mean again this is this
can be done in Steps step one was to
reorganize 612 so that it makes sense
with how we're reporting and what things
really are step two would be whether you
want to remove the word trust from
everywhere that it's not really a trust
and then you would be opening up the
original um statute the underlying
statute that not just in 612 but
whatever created it because keep in mind
everything that in 612 comes with a
partner statute El yes what one thing I
would like to add is that this this
section if you if you recall this has a
definition of a trust um so so um I
think perhaps going forward as
legislation is being um
um oppose uh folks should look at the
definition of trust to really understand
if it's going to be a trust or what kind
of fun is being created um in the future
uh going back to uh um Senator Rosen W
your your point about the opu bement
trust that one the language has that the
treasure is a trusty so um my office is
going to look at that a little more
closely and and and understand if we are
actually compliant with that piece
because when the law goes to the extent
to say that uh the treasur is a trustee
I I I need to take a look second a look
at that Senator gray and then
representative Aly well I think
that if we can't come up with a good
name to substitute for the word trust
way to do it is to make a definition in
the front of 612 somewhere that says
although These funds bing bing bing bing
bing bing bing are not true trusts
because true trusts are in 612 whatever
you know they are and then Define them
you know and and I would agree with that
the other thing is sometimes but I've
had conversations with Department of
Justice about the war trust and some of
them when they read it when they read
some of some of the laws they really
think it should be considered trust even
though but but because of the way they
were written or the way the program
works sometimes he can't function as a
trust even though the language and the
law um discusses that it should be a
trust and treated as such so there's
some confusion as to but they will be
able while this bill goes through the
legislature they will be able to bring
up all those things okay and if they
don't like our language then we can
argue about it for the whole
year representative oh I was just going
to say I wouldn't want to get it lost in
the you know again goal number one was
reorganized SU 12 so while the trust
language we've been living with that
reality for many years I I guess I
wouldn't want that to sort of sink our
ship the chair has offered so many
independent amendments this could just
be another one yeah okay representative
oming thank you um I don't see
why settlements can't be considered
trusts with a small t as they are
defined in the 167 168 that are going to
be moved to the front of this document
once they're in the front of the
document that should make it
easier because they are based on a or
maybe we needed more of a definition
than what we've got there in 167
168 but that
are that are maintained under legal
agreements that the state has to follow
I mean establishing us the law is Step
number one right so if if legislators
want to create a trust and and is um
enacting a law so that's step that's
step one perhaps step two is to have a
document to go with that sometimes I I I
am the trustee of some trust that have a
document but there are others that just
function as programs of the state so
that's that's the that's the
complication well the ones that function
as programs of the state
aren't aren't they things we can change
without having to go to the AG's office
I believe so that you just would write a
different law yeah so they shouldn't be
trusts that that's and I agree that the
educ I remember that discussion about
the education trust fund quite well uh
it was put put in there to tell the
citizens that we were
serious and and only for that
purpose right and I think like the
opioid where the basis for that fund is
settlement dollars but the legislature
decided what to do with those dollars it
wasn't an outside party it wasn't a
legal necessarily document that decided
that it was the legislative bill that
set forth how to spend those dollars
where to put
them Senator I mean based on
settlements with these companies we are
obligated to spend them to mitigate
opioid harms right the purpose spend
them on any other purpose we could lose
them in the future so maybe trust isn't
exactly the right word but right the
terms of the negotiated
settlements require that we spend them
in a certain way right for the I will
say the umbrella opioid abatement
purpose but then what you do what
decisions you make under that umbrella
is subject to legislation so it's it's I
don't know if that's one that's sort of
in between it's not a small tea it's not
a large tea I you know it's just the
tobacco settlement is about halfway to
that same same level we we make
decisions on how to do certain things
and then they interfere if we're getting
too far away
from what will give us the money right
but I mean every
year Jim buetti at the Department of
Justice has to certify to all these drug
manufacturers and Distributors and
wholesalers and pharmacies that they
have been spent in accordance with the
settlement agreement so I
mean um it's we're not really far away
from it like we are with tobacco it's
something he has to do every
year this gets done every year too does
it but it's also Complicated by being
across all well so is is opioid across
all
states any further questions uh for the
treasur and controller on this matter
I would like to see an effort to put it
into some kind of a definition in the
front that says the purpose of what
we're trying to accomplish by moving
some of these trusts you know because I
just looked up Websters you know and it
you know money or or something of value
that's held I mean so that definition
they all fit
into so
trying to say that you know if a trust
has you know a founding document and you
know trust these and and and and all of
those are in this other section then I
think that we can get there all right
so I'm coming to the conclusion that
what we have in front of us is not quite
ready to be put in word for word as a
bill it needs it needs a little bit more
tweaking in particular uh the definition
area also the movement of section 167
and 168 to the front I think would make
sense so can I suggest that perhaps this
would make a bill a good subject of a
bill to be sponsored by Representatives
Aly and
Janan um and go to their committee and
that committee can work on the details
in conjunction with the treasurer and
and uh comproller certainly fine with me
yes yes do we agre I'm sure the house
will do a great job all right Senator
gray even even with bills coming out of
this Committee in the past
years um when you go to OS for drafting
okay they rarely come out the way you've
sent them in sure okay and that's a
reality and so that this recommends that
the bill say this is fine but you as a
legislature have the ability to modify
what you put your name on for sponsoring
it so I'm good with
it representative Jenny again you
have yeah it's going to be a lot more
discussion obviously all right so
but the point is you have you have a
month or so before the deadline so you
can you can get together with them and
and right knock out some details that
way okay all right thank you now um so I
think we're done with that um I actually
had a question based on one of our other
funds for the treasurer as long as she's
here and that is um one of the last ones
that were sort of an open question was
in the Department of
Education and its fund
number let's see here uh School building
authority number 178 on the spreadsheet
it's page four the second
item so the reason I'm bringing this up
is I I had a discussion I spoke for
maybe a half hour today to the chair of
the school building authority which is
representative Hill and and the
treasurer happens to be a member of the
school building
authority and
um
so this is a fund that we've been
putting $5,000 a year into for the last
three years and there's been no spending
and the reason is that representative
Hill didn't know that the fund
exists and he has no need for it so you
know we'll talk about getting rid of it
in a moment but but my question for you
uh madam treasure in particular is if
you look at the the law language that
creates the school building
authority one of the big items there is
they allow school projects to be
guaranteed by the state and there and
that in particular there's up to a $95
million total guarantee that the state
is allowed to to do and what
representative Hill told me is that all
that is obsolete because school projects
now go under some other area of Law and
they no longer need this state guarantee
is that
correct all I know is that it hasn't
been used and I know most schools go
through for example the municipal bomb
bank for their projects um and so the um
the pce that really happens with school
Bill and eight is is really the grant
part of not not the bond fing part it
doesn't so it doesn't come to the State
anymore schools don't use the guarantee
it goes through the uh bom Bank the bom
Bank provides them a good deal
essentially um more better than them
going by themselves and the bond bank is
in law in some other chapter and I'm
also a member of the board okay fine
thank you the question representative W
question arises when you go for a bond
rating and they look at our overall debt
is this in included in the overall debt
it is not it is not it it is not um no
the for our rating they only look at
what's outstand what the state has
outstanding um they understand some of
the moral obligations of the state but
but that's the extent it becomes really
critical if for example um like the
business Finance Authority for example
they they the state also guarantees some
of their bond or most of their bonds if
they were to uh default that will be the
problem
but for example a BFA has enough um
protections and and and and layers to
ensure that they're not they're
protecting themselves first to make sure
the state doesn't have to end up um
paying um that debt well like you I'm
very very cognizant of the fact that if
we get too deep in debt that our bond
rating goes down and the borrowing rates
go up so I'm delighted that it's not
included in the overall debt thank you
it is not we're constantly watching that
as part of our debt affordability
study thank you thank you so
representative W
so what that means is we can just leave
it the way we've got
it as I understand it but well what I'm
going to propose is that since this
whole SE that whole
chapter um requires a more significant
uh bill that it won't be part of our
bill but we will I will together with
representative Hill put in a bill to to
make a more significant change that
whole chapter including removing the
dedicated fund and the $8 a day that his
committee is supposed to be paid and you
know some other other stuff that's
obsolete there so
yeah okay
all right thank you very much any other
questions for the treasurer or
controller today thank you thank you
very much ladies okay all right so now
let's go on to our final report
here and since we just got it presuma
since we just got it presumably we will
like to read
it before we vote
on we have it we have it isn't it this
memorandum
yes November 1st yes thank you all right
let's take a few minutes and read
it
for
e
for for
should be 32 and
at the bottom of page two it should be F
32 and 341 32 is the real estate
appr and
341 is Advanced
manufactur
yeah another one on in in the second um
the end of this going on to the next
page it'll just be Department of Ed and
oplc
sections okay thank
you add in are we ready to discuss no
not quite
okay finding other things
I counted up all the repeal counted up
all the repeals and it's actually only
281 dedicated funds now which I'm
delighted because when we talk about we
got more than 300 dedicated funds and
we're not going to add another one are
we some are still
yeah
for
e
e e
see
about it for the
elction
e
for e
I I'll wait a moment for Senator gr to
come back
about
Dragon start
all right so let's go Page by page and
if we have any corrections on a given
page we'll
go over them all right the first page
any I don't think there's anything no
okay good no
32 yeah page two um Jennifer said that
um we number 348 should really be
32 that was on page page two the very
last line
yeah any other corrections to page
two okay let's go on to page three and
she wants to write um on the very first
line uh Department of Education and oplc
sections
any other corrections to page three yes
okay represent all
me on fund
1567 at the bottom of page three uh
three up on they have dumped all sorts
of different things into 167 I think we
need to use the
Aus every time we get to fund 167
because they're all different programs
tiptop house is still alive and is in
there several things we're getting rid
of are in
there are you going to say buy a
accounting unit somewhere or yeah just
under the fund these were particularly
Harriet and Hattie yeah the Harriet and
hat Hattie are in there too um
right so yeah that is yes right so so
you want to put in the accounting units
for for just for
167 right in that little for those two
funds yes yeah I've got them on the
spreadsheets if
you
okay other correction to page
three
okay page four I have a
few um so uh we're going to add the word
unencumbered on robotics capping the
unencumbered balance second line oh
yeah is that
right
okay
um so um on fund 178 we're going to
spell the word School
correctly
[Laughter]
oh okay and um I would add a sentence at
the end of that um the chair and SBA
chair will cooperate on
legislation or on this legislation
something like that Mr chair yes Senator
rosemore thank you um I think that the
phrase uh the well the committee
recommends future
legislation to propose changes to
modernize School building authority
statutes overall goes beyond the scope
of this
committee um and we don't know what
you're going to be proposing so I I'm
hoping that we you don't want to commit
to it in advance right no I was hoping
we could just say recommends future
legislation to propose changes to the
provision for member compensation and
related fund and then anything else that
you're looking at that's not related to
the dedicated funds wouldn't be part of
this
report all right so you're you just want
to remove the words to
modernize um
well School building authority statutes
overall
including
the or I mean including so that would
say the committee
recommends future legislation to propose
changes to the provision for member
compensation gotcha and the related fund
because that's really what we've talked
about to modernize okay so we're going
to cross out the words modernized School
building authority statutes overall
comma including yes thank you okay and
um are you okay with having me add the
sentence the chair and the SBA chair
will cooperate on
legislation sure I mean you obviously
can do whatever you want sure but but I
mean that's our intention so don't point
it on just just to who's doing it kind
of right right and not what you're doing
but who
yeah I mean who were sort of assigning
this task to kind of thing okay all
right other changes to this page I just
like to say on that one the entire
education statutes needs this kind of
upgrade
so well remember one at a time remember
that the bill was in to to redo the
whole statute but we also have a statute
that says the people that are supposed
to be in charge that are LBA and that
didn't sit well with the education
people so they kind of nixed the the re
right is that the one we put 100,000 in
to hire a lawyer to go through yep and
then I put in another 100,000 for the
LBA
lawyer and that didn't go well with the
education people than they want to be
you know the fox in charge of the the
hen
house okay and I don't want them to be
that I swear they've got stuff about Ox
carts in
there it's
just um and they have the same subject
in multiple Place places with different
interpretations on so exactly the chair
and S ba a chair will
collaborate yes I I had the word
cooperate but
cooperate on legisl words to the effect
cooperate other changes to page
four uh oh yeah
um where president M fund
348 the fund was actually established in
09 and then they they removed the
funding mechanism in 17 and then they
put back another funding mechanism in
19 it's got a lot more history than that
yeah so on this one I how about last
modified in 19 yeah
okay okay last modified okay instead of
establish
okay um I'm not sure I reported on this
but I I spoke extensively well I spoke
to with the chair of this um there's a
committee that that deals with this and
that's um representative Mark
Pearson uh is the chair of that
committee and I spoke with him and
um because I told him maybe we should
repeal this entire chapter which was
200m I think um because nothing's ever
been done right and his committee hasn't
met and things like that and he wasn't
willing to go that far what he wanted to
do was put in a study committee to
decide what is appropriate for this
area and um so I backed off a little bit
and um I'm willing to do that with him
but I don't know if we need to say all
that stuff here so yeah I guess given
that oh okay the rest of that is all
right so I take it Senator Ros didn't
have any other changes correct okay
thank you all right anything else on
page
four
okay I I don't have anything on page
five does anyone
else no no okay page six I
do uh no I guess I'm going to save this
for the end
um and there's nothing in the middle
there about uh the housekeeping measures
are not just off book it is the question
of what are
trusts okay
to Define to Define and and right uh
created a
section of the whole def definition
section that that explains this before
we get into one two three four right so
first of all it should be State
Treasurer mespelli and comproller Dana
call right yeah because they're together
on
this um
uh so that we reflect the AL book
stuff um comma provide
guidance
well
and
um uh look into the
definitions
of of trust
funds right and
um add
definitions oh and add definitions okay
right right okay
definitions of trust
funds okay
repealing the deleting the word trust
from funds which are not TRS okay
[Music]
including um renaming
funds that do not
meet those
definitions
okay my concern those may be refer to
another places well yeah when you rename
something they do a global search and
rename it
everywhere yeah I mean that's just the
normal part of the drafting process at
least it is
recently or it should be yeah it is okay
um I'm not going to mention here that
you guys are going to do it I'm going to
put that at the end okay
okay all right so what we have
is
um so that it's the treasurer and the
controller
um request requesting the transfer to
the accounting system Etc
and um add definitions of trust
funds
um in including
renaming uh funds that do not meet those
definitions are you was okay with that
Jennifer yeah okay good anything else on
this page maybe renaming and
reclassifying in C or
D re renaming and clar and classifying
as C or
D
okay okay any go ahead just to follow up
on that what happens in cases where the
it's been in statute somewhere else and
given that name and now we're renaming
it how I mean I guess how is that
reconciled or is it reconciled by the
fact that we have a new statute that
says I guess that's what it is we're now
renaming your bill would you know if
it's in RSA
1234 uh fund such and such right that
your bill would have a line that says
change change you know amend RSA
1234 you know fund such and such is now
fund thus and so right you know so it
and it's now in section well if it so so
your bill will not just amend chapter 6
but it will also amend chapter 1 two 3 4
where it changes the but it would just
be a name change right we had that with
dogs and cats with the agriculture
program you remember how complicated
that got yeah yeah renaming yeah a lot
of name changes yeah an example would be
when they change the name of a
department or split or combine a
department is that you end up with a
bill that is multiple pages long because
every time that department is listed
they have to go in and put the statute
yeah yeah yeah I I have a bill um that
changes the responsibility from the
attorney general to the state so all
there's a whole bunch of places where it
crosses off attorney general and changes
it to State and then but it's but it's
really w a global change anyways so at
the bottom of that one I wanted to point
out 167 Matthew Elliot trust
fund oh okay so again you want the
accounting unit there is that it yes
okay
good okay page
seven no on okay did we actually
discuss finance division one sorting out
the 16 off book funds in 168 all right
so this is left over from last year ah
so I asked
any kind of ongoing thing related to the
budget um that was in last year's report
I asked Jennifer to continue in this
report just so it would help me remember
it for Budget time right good is that
all right yep okay yeah that was a last
year thing okay and you also have
appendix D in this which is the
treasures proposal to clean up the off
book account
but it's not included in what we've got
so far right yeah all this report will
be accompanied by all the minutes and uh
you know appendices and things like that
and some of them like that one will be
work in progress all right one at a time
um let's representative Al well some of
them will be work in progress rather
than final report that are the ENT
sure absolutely Jennifer
sure yeah okay so at the bottom of that
page page seven seven yeah okay
um should you put in who is going to be
responsible for following up on fund
and well that'll be the committee
legislation all these things are
committee legislation that I will
sponsor okay and hopefully you will too
so
yeah okay we should probably all be
asked yes we will all be
asked because these are all the yeah
unanimous simple you know whatever
straightforward stuff okay
well not so sure the state park account
Kanan Mountain ski account is going to
be so simple well maybe not
okay
um
um anything else on page seven page
eight I have adding the word
unencumbered in front of balance for
robotics oh
yeah and I want to add on this off book
thing that and we can add the the the
more detail there that of what's in the
proposal but that I want to add a
sentence that that um Representatives
Ali and
janigian will uh um Carry forward with
this
legislation carry this legislation
forward so it's not just off book
anymore that's right
so well specifically about the
um TR
yes right so so rather than calling it
offb book accounts maybe we'll call it
um
RSA
6 cleanup right six 12 six colon 12 yeah
yeah six colon 12 cleanup yeah that
should be the title of
that maybe we could add that
where we talked about off book before
too
yes well it didn't have a title it just
six well it just said
on we added we added stuff onto that
yeah yeah I think we're
okay all right anything else on page
eight all right Senator gray would you
like to make a motion
like to get out of
here well your
power move to approve as amended is that
the one motion you wanted yes
please right uh seconded by
representative
janigian any further discussion all in
favor say I I I any oppos no all right I
think we can
adjourn thank you very much for this
year thank you yes and thank you
gent yes thank you very much
yes if anyone is interested in attending
the audit of the voting machines it will
start at noon time on Wednesday the day
after the election and go until finished
on Thursday
it's going to go past
midnight
e for